well this is one of the problems with
this left-wing gender ideology is that
no one who espouses it
can even tell you what these words means
like what is a woman
can you tell me what a woman is
no i can't
because it's not for me to say
womanhood looks different for everybody
what do you what do you define a woman
as an adult human female and what does a
female mean
uh
how do you define it someone with with
female reproductive organs
okay someone who's you know here's the
thing when you're when you're female it
goes right down to your bones your dna
so that's why if someone
dies okay we could dig up their bones a
hundred years from now we have no idea
what they believed in their head but we
can tell what sex they were because it's
in it's down in it's it's ingrained in
every fiber of their being interesting
so i'm trying to understand your
definition is that a woman is someone
who is female you said right correct is
a biological female so what happens if
we have maybe someone who is female
identifies as a woman right you know
cisgender woman right as you explain as
you just explained
it maybe doesn't have the ability to
reproduce
maybe doesn't have those organs that
you're talking about that are
reproductive organs i have answered the
question
you stood up here and said trans women
are women yes tell me what you mean what
is a womanhood is something that just as
ethan explained i cannot define because
i am not myself
so what did you mean when you said trans
women are women if you don't know what
it means
so here's the thing so i do not define
what a woman is because i do not
identify as a woman womanhood is
something that is an umbrella term it
includes people that describes what
people who identify as a woman i
identify as what as a woman what is that
was to each their own each woman each
man each person is going to have a
different relation with their own gender
identity and define it differently so
trans women
are women too okay
[Applause]
and we want to hold up
you want to reduce men down to maybe
just their genetics our genitals our
chromosomes right that's what you want
to do is that's what what you want to do
is appropriate women you want to
appropriate womanhood okay and turn it
into basically a costume that could be
worn we've got when we've it's real
funny it's real funny it's real funny
when you're looking like right so man
you're literally saying this is what a
woman is yeah what that is
because i am willing to define it but
you won't